Oh
[Music]
Kevin Kelley has a great line about
humans in our symbiotic relationship
with technology he says we are the
creators and we are the creative and of
course this echoes this notion of
ontological design and that everything
that we design is designing us back we
have been in a cybernetic feedback loop
with our technologies since the
beginning of early hominins playing with
stone tools and in scribing their
interior world onto clay tablets with
little glyphs of meaning the minute that
we started to extend our mind we're out
into the world we've been turning the
mine inside out technology is our second
skin our exoskeleton literally we are
exterior izing our nervous system our
mind where's McKenna likes to say and
we've been doing it forever this is the
most natural thing in the world it is
what it means to be human right Kevin
Kelly's beautiful example is the moment
we discovered fire and thus cook it we
all of a sudden created an external
stomach and could pre digest our food so
that we could absorb that many more
nutrients from every meal and not waste
all this time eating raw food all day
long just to basically stay nourished
instead we're freeing up cognitive
realistic freeing the minds for other
endeavors so essentially externalizing
our stomach through fire turn this
technology into a part of us beyond our
in tissue in whose feedback group and
engagement with said technology opened
up a new space for a Cambrian explosion
of mind
fire and cooking essentially made us
human but again larger metaphor here the
larger message here is that a symbiotic
relationships with these tools actually
is who we are our mind is distributed
between brains tool technologies and
environments this is where we are we are
as Andy Clark says the natural-born
cyborg we are the creators but we are
the created what we create is creating
us back the feedback loop is a symbol of
life not the DNA molecule the feedback
loop the loop that's us
you